Новини дня «heute» з Митрієм Зіріним.
Добрий вечір усім.
Сьогодні Норберт розповість
про дві головні події у світі футболу.
А також актуальні новини з Англії.
Теми нашого випуску цієї неділі:
12 тижнів війни в Україні:
служби розвідки висловлюють побоювання
щодо майбутніх нових
інтенсивних атак російських військ.
У пошуках нових енергетичних партнерів:
Федеральний канцлер Шольц відвідав Сенеґал
під час свого першого візиту до Африки.
Місто в екстазі: Лейпциг святкує
першу перемогу своєї команди Бундесліги
в Кубку Німеччини з футболу.
Росія посилює атаки на Сході України,
зокрема, здійснює великий наступ на Луганщині,
одній з двох областей Донбасу.
Там російські військові впродовж кількох днів
намагаються заблокувати транспортні маршрути.
Про ситуацію, яку президент України
Зеленський називає «надзвичайно складною»,
розповість Аксель Конрад.
Місто Бахмут на Донбасі.
«Прифронтовий глибокий тил» - так називають
цю територію на військовому жаргоні.
Для мешканців це означає,
що ракети можуть вдарити в будь-який момент.
Нещодавно одна з них влучила в університет.
Я саме йшла на автобусну станцію.
Це мене врятувало.
Росіяни атакують переважно з повітря.
Театралізовані пропагандистські відео
Міністерства оборони
показали гелікоптери Ка-52 у дії.
Мета - відрізати міста Сєвєродонецьк і Лисичанськ
від постачання військових припасів
із Заходу.
Ворог планує оточити міста
і зрештою взяти під контроль
усю територію Донбасу.
А тут мешканці сподіваються на те,
що найгірше вже позаду.
Це - село Мощун поблизу Києва.
Росіяни покинули село,
Зінаїда Костенко вже повернулася додому .
Крім неї, в селі досі майже ніхто не живе,
однак 67-річна мешканка вже має сміливі плани.
Ми відкриємо наш магазин,
щойно знову з'явиться світло.
Хлопці лагодять лінії й кажуть,
що вже в кінці місяця відновлять його.
Ми все відбудуємо і житимемо, як раніше.
У Києві в парламенті лунають палкі оплески
на честь дуже близького союзника.
Президент Польщі Дуда
наголошує на праві Києва на самовизначення.
Не може бути жодних переговорів і рішень
за спиною України,
нічого не відбуватиметься без вас.
Це - залізний принцип.
З тривогою переносимо увагу зі столиці на Одесу.
Сьогоднішній спокій може бути оманливим.
За словами міського очільника,
Чорноморський флот Росії
здійснює підготовку до нападу.
Йоганнес Гано з нами на зв'язку з Одеси.
Українська розвідка отримала нову інформацію.
Про що вона попереджає?
Українська розвідка попередила населення про те,
що російські війська привели в бойову готовність
на кордоні з Україною балістичні ракети
малої дальності типу «Іскандер».
Це рішення не віщує нічого хорошого,
адже ці ракети дуже цінні для росіян.
По-перше, це високоточна зброя, а по-друге,
росіяни мають не так вже й багато таких ракет.
Це означає, що росіяни дуже сподіваються
на цю зброю і можуть використати її
для масивних ударів, зокрема,
по стратегічній інфраструктурі України
і по військах на Донбасі, які зараз
чинять опір російській армії.
Тож такі побоювання небезпідставні,
про це й попередили населення.
Загалом попереду українців чекають складні часи.
Наживо з Одеси - Йоганнес Гано. Щиро дякую.
Росія продовжує блокувати
експорт зерна з України.
Такі дії посилюють продовольчу кризу
у Східній Африці.
Звісно, це питання було одним
з головних під час першого візиту до Африки
федерального канцлера Шольца.
Він відвідав Сенеґал, Ніґер і Південну Африку.
Серед інших тем зустрічі були також
питання зміни клімату й енергопостачання,
а також значний вплив Китаю й Росії
на африканський континент.
З Сенеґалу для нас
підготував сюжет Клаус Бродбек.
Перший візит до Африки,
перша зупинка - місто Дакар.
Сенеґал вважають одним з ключових партнерів
Німеччини та Європи.
Наразі держава очолює Африканський Союз
і є однією із двох африканських країн,
яких канцлер запросив у червні на саміт G7.
Олаф Шольц намагається
здобути прихильність країни.
Наше завдання - підтримувати країни світу,
які дотримуються міжнародного права
і з якими ми висловлюємо взаємну солідарність.
У цьому прагненні для нас важлива кожна країна,
і Німеччина розраховує на Сенеґал.
На зустрічі обговорювали питання
боротьби з тероризмом
й наслідки війни в Україні.
Африці загрожує голод, Сенеґал сподівається на
фінансову й технічну підтримку Німеччини
для освоєння газового родовища біля узбережжя.
Політики торгуються.
Я думаю, що ми знайдемо надійного
партнера для діалогу в Німеччині,
але є й інші варіанти.
Широкий спектр тем, як-от енергетична безпека
і наслідки війни в України для Африки,
канцлер порушував і в інших місцях
під час своєї подорожі.
Шольц прагне пояснити,
що він серйозно переймається
континентом і його проблемами,
а заразом бажає витіснити
щораз більший вплив Росії та Китаю на регіон.
Для цього Німеччина надає Сенеґалу
сонячну електростанцію -
відновне джерело енергії в Африці.
Минуло два роки перерви
через пандемію COVID-19,
і ось знову в Давосі стартує
Всесвітній економічний форум.
На зустрічі у Швейцарських Альпах
йдеться про наслідки пандемії,
війну в Україні та зміну клімату -
П'ять днів обміну думками між політиками,
економістами й громадянським суспільством.
Анне Ґеллінек розповість більше з місця подій.
«Переломний момент історії» - таке гасло
має форум у Давосі.
Наскільки це відчувається
і які можуть бути результати зустрічі?
Дуже чітко можна відчути, що ця зустріч
відрізняється від усіх попередніх.
Ситуація у світі має безпосередній
вплив на список запрошених гостей.
Росію повністю виключили з нього
через напад на Україну.
Китайська делегація менша, ніж у минулі роки:
з одного боку, через пандемію, з іншого -
через політичне відмежування від Заходу.
Тому Захід тут розмовляє сам з собою, а світ щораз
відчутніше ділиться на блоки: США - Китай - Європа.
Через це постає питання, чи взагалі ідея про
глобалізацію міжнародного
поділу праці має майбутнє.
Тож цього року в Давосі спостерігаємо
менше «блиску» й більше роздумів.
Дякую, Анне Ґелінек.
Пів години тому ми отримали повідомлення про те,
що наступного тижня у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії
CDU і Зелені планують
розпочати попередні консультації щодо
можливого утворення коаліції.
Представники CDU і Зелених
повідомили, що обидві партії погодилися на це.
І вже вдруге цього тижня
маємо фантастичну новину, пов'язану з футболом.
Цього разу в центрі уваги опинився Лейпциг.
Тисячі шанувальників гучно святкують перемогу
нового володаря Кубка Німеччини.
Пікап команди-переможця поїхав на велику вечірку
перед ареною, де, ймовірно,
святкування триватиме допізна.
З цих святкових кадрів починаємо
говорити про спортивні успіхи Лейпцига,
а отже, час новин від Норберта Кеніґа.
Майже до 13 річниці від заснування
«РБ Лейпциг»
саксонці бездоганно виборюють
першу гучну перемогу
проти клубу Фрайбурга.
У меншості вони грали додаткову годину,
а з пенальті вийшли з міцнішими нервами.
Ермедін Демирович забив вирішальний
пенальті повз ворота,
позбавивши Фрайбург перемоги,
хоч команда й домінувала на полі
впродовж першої половини гри
й заслужено була лідеркою.
Максіміліан Еґґештайн
забив гол вже на 19-й хвилині.
Під час контратаки Фрайбурга
у другій половині матчу
Марсель Гальстенбер звалив з ніг Лукаса Гелера -
безперечно, червона картка.
Лейпциг боровся в меншості
і нарешті на 76-й хвилині
Крістофер Нкунку зрівняв рахунок -
це вже святкували, як перемогу.
Але лише після додаткового часу
й вдалого пенальті
команда здобула справжню перемогу в Кубку.
У надзвичайно захопливій дуелі проти Ліверпуля
«Манчестер Сіті» здобув перемогу
в англійській Прем'єр-лізі.
Перемога проти Вулвергемптона не допомогла
Ліверпулю, адже «Манчестер Сіті»,
який відставав з рахунком 0:2,
переміг з рахунком 3:2,
випередивши Ліверпуль на одне очко.
Як Ліверпуль гратиме наступної суботи
у фіналі Ліги чемпіонів
проти команди «Реал Мадрид»,
можна буде побачити наживо на сторінці «ZDF».
Чоловіча національна збірна Німеччини з хокею
відсвяткувала п'ятий успішний матч поспіль
на Чемпіонаті світу у Фінляндії.
Після перемоги з рахунком 5:4 проти Казахстану
команді пророчать групову перемогу
в матчі проти Швейцарії.
Макс Ферстаппен переміг у
«Red Bull» Гран-прі Іспанії.
Це третя перемога поспіль
для чемпіона світу Формули-1.
Попри виліт у гравійну пастку,
нідерландцю в Барселоні вдалося
пробитися вперед
і скористатися невдачею
Шарля Леклера на Ferrari,
який досі був попереду.
Себастьян Феттель - 11-й,
тож залишається без балів,
як і Мік Шумахер, який фінішував 14-м.
Ферстаппен здобуває першість на Чемпіонаті світу
з перевагою в шість балів,
залишаючи позаду Леклера.
А тепер - короткий огляд погоди.
Завтра на Заході та Півдні Німеччини
очікуються дощі й грози,
вдень та ввечері також подекуди буде негода
з сильним дощем, градом й ураганними шквалами.
На Півночі й Сході сонячно, 20-28°.
На цьому наші короткі новини завершуються.
Також радимо подивитися «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом о 21:45.
Чекатимемо на вас завтра о 19:00.